- Dudes that were trying to kill it
didn't use words like empathy
and gratitude seven years ago.
Like, just, like seeing sleeved up,
rad dudes roll to me
like, yo, kindness, dog!
I'm like, it's just so...
(dramatic music)
What's the context?
What's the framework?
Help me understand how.
- Okay.
- 'Cause I never know
what's going on in my life.
- There's gonna be a lot
of small business owners.
And then a ton of hungry soon to be,
if not already, entrepreneurs.
Fresh LLC shit like that.
- Yup, and how many people?
- A thousand, we're gonna,
we're gonna have in between,
dude, we've been gunnin' dog.
- Clearly.
- [Man] Like we've been gunnin', man.
I'm telling you bro, it
all started with just,
I had zero dollars and
I was like, oh shit.
- You worked it backwards.
- [Man] Yeah, bro, we
had to make it happen.
Um, this is all based on
a belief where I knew.
- You made the bet.
- [Man] Yeah, my city needed Gary Vee.
- I'm here.
- [Man] I'm telling
you, dog, say it again.
- I'm here, I'm in the building.
- [Man] We got him, dog.
♪ Oh yeah ♪
♪ Swear to God, I'm with it ♪
♪ I don't see nobody in my
lanes, quite go get it ♪
♪ Like me ♪
♪ Please don't be wastin'
my time with that business ♪
♪ Who you kiddin' man ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Oh yeah, swear to God I'm with it ♪
♪ I don't see nobody givin'
my lanes quite go get it ♪
♪ Like me, oh ♪
- To be good enough to
build an actual business
that lets you live off of it,
you have to work your fucking face off.
To work your face off, it'd
be nice if you liked it.
If you like, hated it
because, but you thought
it was gonna get you
money, you've already lost.
And so, to me, it's about
what process will you love,
if you're lucky like me, that
your process that you love
is also something that
will help you make money,
that's why you, you know, have it.
But like, if my children, or for example,
people don't know me, like
if I was just super artistic
and didn't have entrepreneurial DNA,
I would have been super pumped.
And I mean this,
I want everyone to really
hear this, nice and slow.
I would have been super
pumped making $68,000 a year
making wood carvings because
I just can't wrap around
any process that looks like
I do something that doesn't
make me happy in a world
where working takes up
more than half your life.
If you look into how much
you'll work in your life
and how much you sleep, I just,
I can't wrap my head around it.
So, anyway, I think the best business
is something you actually like.
It's like a relationship, like,
it'd be nice if you liked the person.
(audience chuckles)
- Who want's pictures with Gary?
Okay, we got 15 minutes, and
then we gotta get you all
to the front row so we can, let's stop,
let's stop emptying this gas tank.
We gotta keep it going.
- There's so much more.
(upbeat music)
Dudes that were trying to
kill it didn't use words
like empathy and
gratitude seven years ago.
Like, seeing like sleeved up,
like rad dudes roll up to
me like, yo, kindness, dog!
I'm like, it's just so, and
honestly I genuinely believe
my great legacy potentially
may be that I made
emotionally intelligent,
soft skills alpha.
You know, you'll never believe this,
this is super interesting to me.
The fact that pink was a boy's color
and blue was girl's color back in the day
is kinda how I think about
gratitude, empathy, kindness.
I'm like, I'm gonna trick
these young fuckin' dogs
into like, thinking this shit is cool.
And then one day in 50 years,
people are gonna be like,
the alpha male traits are
like gratitude and kindness.
And if I could pull that
off, then it's like!
I'm super fired up to be here.
Thank you so much for having me.
(crowd cheers)
So, there's several different things
running through my mind,
but let me start with this
because I want to get a
sense for the audience.
How many people here are entrepreneurs?
Raise your hand.
Very nice, thank you.
Quite a bit.
Working in a small business?
Very nice.
Corporate jobs?
Great, great.
Everyone's like, me, fuck.
(crowd laughing)
Awesome, that's what I needed.
So, looking at the hands,
here's where I want to go this evening,
I think the biggest thing that
is on my mind as I stand here tonight,
and I appreciate the wonderful welcome,
is including myself, and fuck,
I spend every minute trying
to understand all of this,
I think that everybody in here is
underestimating how special this era is.
(hip hop music)
Thank you guys, thanks for coming!
Thank you, thank you, bye!
You know, you come from a super high,
you know, that kind of love.
The audience was super in it.
You know, sometimes you
just have the audience
like at your fucking
fingertips, you can just,
it's like a yo-yo, you
can do anything with it.
That audience and I were
speaking the same language.
And, you know, I go
through rhythms and uh...
Oh, we don't need to go here, sir.
- [Driver] We don't? Okay.
- Nope.
- [Driver] We're going
right to the airport?
- Yeah, you know where we're going?
- [Driver] Yeah, yeah, Signature? Yup.
- Yup, thank you.
And so, I'm feeling great, I
thought it went really well.
You know, so, you're coming
down form a high, you know?
Coming down from a high.
(hip hop music)
On some level, it's all improv, man.
If you notice, like the
way I started the keynote,
it's like, super happy to be here,
you could see, my head's racing.
So when I wanna talk, literally
at the point I'm like,
100 percent in!
But tension, humility, like it
could go absolutely anywhere.
- [Interviewer] And that gives
you a rush, though, right?
- Yeah, I just, I'm so
naturally gifted in improv.
I have so much to say.
You what it is, you're
starting to learn this,
it's cause I'm doing all
day, I'm doing all week,
there's so much going on.
- [Interviewer] I could tell
how the different conversations
throughout the week fed into this.
- Cool, isn't it?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, it's crazy.
- It's crazy.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
(atmospheric music)